We do this exercise with a
little wagon wheel of like,
where are you with your health, your
energy, your income, your family,
your friends, your love. And that thing
always looked like a jagged wheel,
like lots of money, lots of this
fun's. Great. Ooh, this is not good.
This is the first time ever. It's
a really round wheel in my life.
And right now they're all kind of
hitting on all cylinders. What.
Would your typical message be to somebody
if they went through that wagon wheel
exercise and they were
hitting it on all cylinders?
What would you tell that person.
If they were hitting it on all cylinders?
I'd probably say the full of shit.
And any other time in my
life I would say that. But.
Dean, thanks for making the time here.
I think you're known super well for
all of your mindset, habits, success,
all of that.
I wanted to go a little different angle
with you today and talk marketing.
Let's do it.
I think people don't see behind the
scenes of everything that you're doing and
the massive success that you've had
sold over 2 million books and everything
else you've done.
What are some of the high level
strategies you're using right now on the
marketing side to really push the needle?
Yeah, it's kind of like art and science.
It's tactical and 30,000 foot.
So maybe we'll start with some higher
level stuff and then you drill down as far
as you want to go. I think one of the
biggest things when it comes to selling,
everybody always asks what color page
you're using, what's your headline?
What arrow are you using?
How long are your videos?
Or how short are your videos? And
I think all of those are important,
but minimally compared to
the depth that I believe of
loving what you do so much that you feel
like you're doing a disservice to the
world if you don't get it in their
hands. And I say that for you.
You were just sitting here earlier talking
to me and talking to Joe Polish and
you were saying, I get mad
because people, you get pissed.
You were saying that about Jim Rohn,
more of the world needs to know Jim Rome.
You're mad that more of the world
doesn't know Jim Rohn. Right?
I feel that way when I write a book
like Millionaire Success Habits,
I love that book. I know that when people
read it, they're going nuts over it.
It impacts their life. So
using your terminology,
I get mad if I can't get
it in people's hands,
but the opposite side is that I feel
like I'm doing 'em a disservice.
So where some people lean away from
selling, they're afraid to sell. I mean,
my ads are everywhere. People see 'em
on tv, YouTube, Instagram, Facebook.
I'm not afraid of that because I know
if I get them to click and give me their
credit card, I get to impact their lives.
You have that same mission of
getting eyeballs to what you do.
It can impact their life.
So I think the foundation of sales
is don't just love what you do,
obsess on what you do so much that you
literally feel bad if you're not getting
a credit card.
So for me,
that makes me want to do an ad lighting
a book on fire or climbing a mountain or
being in my cryo asana or driving in my
car or anything I can do to get somebody
to stop and impact their lives.
That's kind of the 30,000 foot.
I think the other thing too that I think
we're in an age that most people don't
realize. I've been in the
infomercial space for 21 years,
and entry point is hard. You want to
do an infomercial 10, 15 years ago,
you need a half a million bucks
just to get started today.
Someone can film an ad in their car,
on their phone and have
it on Facebook for $10.
So I think that the entry point is so
much easier that I think people are so
saturated with the same stuff
that they're looking for.
That's why you do so well.
You have a unique way you present it.
So I think we're at a place right
now, I believe with the economy,
the way it's on its way of
shifting just a normal cycle,
I think with the mindset of America and
the world and there's so much crap out
there, well, simultaneously,
there's a lot of good,
I think people are so
hungry for authenticity,
they don't even realize
how hungry they are for it.
I think they're hungry for an imperfect
video that comes from your heart rather
than a perfectly scripted one on the
perfect stage with the perfect lights.
I think they're ready for
your heart revealing things
that you're once scared to
admit. Even the things
you're once embarrassed.
I think we want to know that about people
so we can know if we trust and like
them.
So I think we're at this unique place
in time where you can just be the best
version of yourself and still have the
opportunity to sell without feeling like
a salesman. Does that
make sense? Yeah, yeah.
For sure.
So for mission-driven entrepreneurs
who then have a book or have a product,
what's the tactic to
get it more well known?
What are the three to five things that
you're doing to help sell a million.
Books? So one is most
people think, I mean,
there's a lot of different ways to go
about it. I'm a direct response marketer,
so I spend money. If I spend
a dollar in advertising,
I want to get a dollar 25 back. So
that's just my frame of reference.
There's some people, like my buddy
Trent Shelton has a massive following,
his whole last eight years of obsessed
on getting 7 million people follow him on
Facebook and a million on Instagram.
When he launches his book,
he's got that platform. He's going to do
really well with it. That's one model.
My model was a little different.
I was on TV for so long that I
kind of ignored social media.
You and I talk about that.
That's why you're helping me and you're
so amazing at what you do. So me,
for me to impact and make a presence,
I'm a direct response marketer.
So my model is running
ads that go to a page that
sells or collects the data and put 'em
through a process that I'll explain to
you right now. Do you want the
tactical Go deep? Yeah, let's go deep.
Let's give some value.
So.
First off, you need a sales page.
So if you're a guru or an expert or in
business or in life and you want to write
a book, what most people think when
they write a book and it's kind of dead,
is let me write a book and let me do
whatever I can to get a book deal.
I think book deals are dead, and I think
it's actually dumb in today's world.
The world has changed.
That's why borders is gone.
That's why a blockbuster is gone in
a different way. It's a new medium.
We have the opportunity to get our
product in front of people's faces cheaper
and easier with the exact demographic
than ever before. Right? If I look at,
I sold a million books on an
infomercial in 2007 to 2009,
that's casting a big net.
That's hoping somebody walks by a TV and
happens to what I'm in today's world,
if you want to build a book,
if you had something for pregnant moms
who make 75 grand a year that like peanut
butter and jelly,
you could find that demographic.
So you're able to niche down so
far in today's world. So
whatever your niche is,
niche it down and go after that
audience, which is obvious. You get that.
So for me, I have a sales page. My
strategy is giving a book away for free.
I do pay for the book and I ask people
to cover the shipping and handling.
So what that does is I have a
page where it's selling nonstop.
So it's one page that everybody can go
to and 24 hours a day, seven days a week,
that's an advertisement.
There's a video of me offering my book
free plus shipping and handling with some
bonuses. That makes sense. That's obvious.
So then my whole world is the art and
science of getting people to that page.
You get eyeballs through
kind of organic growth.
Mine is I'm paying what I can afford
per click to get someone to go to that
page.
So that's YouTube,
Instagram and Facebook and
the art side for me. So again,
I'm kind of going 30,000
foot and tactical all in a,
I've never really shared this publicly,
so this is great. So if I'm not perfect,
the chair it the first, it's
great. That's good. But for me,
it's the art and science.
And how I figure out the art is
I've read probably 20,000 comments
from people that are following me and
I want to know what they worry about,
what keeps 'em up at night, what their
dreams are, what their goals are,
and I want to match that.
I combine matching that with trying to
be the most authentic version of myself.
Literally before I film ads.
I'm like, stop with the hype.
Stop what you're thinking about right now
and how do you live inside their fear?
How do you live inside what
they're worried about? And
I've been in business for
over 30 years. I did live in a trailer
park as a kid. I didn't go to college.
So we all have our journey, but I know
what it feels like on every level.
So I try to put myself in
different circumstances.
I put myself in the
beginning, entrepreneur,
maybe someone just got out of college,
they don't know what
to do with their life.
I want that person to
know they're understood.
But I also know what it's like for baby
boomers who've been in a job for 30
years and they feel like they wasted
30 years. I want to live in their mind.
So every time I do a video,
I'm trying to live in the mind of the
different people that could potentially
watch. Does that make sense? Yeah.
So when people ask me
long video or short video,
I'll tell you it doesn't matter. My two
best sales videos that I've ever done,
two best ads, one is 58 seconds,
and that's probably sold 50,000
books and one is 36 minutes.
So length has nothing to do with
it. Impact does feeling connected,
does having the ability to watch
a video from beginning to end.
So I have this main page
that I drive everybody to.
It doesn't matter if I'm on
Instagram, Facebook, YouTube.
If I do a podcast with somebody great
like Ed Millet or Andy Fer or do a video
with Tony, I do something with you.
I'm going to drive everybody to this one
place because that sales mechanism just
works 24 hours, seven days a week.
So they go to that page and that's where
people need to obsess on conversions.
If somebody goes there,
does 1% of the people buy the book or
10% and you just want to obsess to get
that to the highest percentage possible.
When that's set,
then your whole job is just
driving eyeballs. And when
someone buys a free book,
for me,
what I hope is I deliver so much value
that I lose money when I give a book away
for free. People don't realize that,
but when people get to know me,
and I'm not saying that in a bragging way,
but as Tony said, you have
the depth and breadth.
I've been in business for 30
years. I've been up and down.
I've generated over a billion dollars
with my brands and my company.
When people get to hear
me or they get to read,
they know that I have what it takes
to help them. So because of that,
I can lose money on that book,
but I know they like what I have,
that they buy all my other
products. And at the end of the day,
at the end of 90 days,
even though I lost money giving away my
book and we're almost at 500,000 copies
at the end of 90 days, they're
like, this guy's a badass.
I'm getting this course. I'm
going to go to his mastermind.
I'm going to get this
training. And all of a sudden,
that buyer that was in the negative is
valuable to me and they stay with us for
life. I don't know if I
explained that in a way that.
No, that's So what's the process after?
So I get my book, I paid the shipping,
five bucks, six bucks, eight
bucks, 10 bucks, whatever it is.
Now I'm on your list.
What's going to happen next?
So for our list, if
someone's already on it,
we about 90% of what we do is
deliver value on a weekly basis.
I sent out a video, it's called Weekly
Wisdom. I've been sending those out for,
this is our 10th year. So they get value
every single week to build reciprocity.
And then probably once a quarter,
sometimes once every six months,
I'll have an offer or an
opportunity. Right now,
Tony Robinson and I are working on a
new course, totally stoked about that.
My list will get nothing but love for the
next couple months until I launch that
course with Tony and they'll be like, Hey,
gave you lots of love built
relationship. You ready for something?
This is next level. And the list, I say
list, but I like calling 'em my family.
They realize that I look after 'em.
It's not offer after offer after until
they opt out. That's some people's model.
It's like squeeze 'em until they go.
I'd rather love 'em until I'm
ready to offer 'em something.
And that's proven really good
for us when we launch a product.
We've done tens of millions of dollars
in launches after the initial purchase
because we delivered value even
above, over and above the book.
So you're going to send a weekly video?
We do. We send a weekly video forever.
And this is stuff you record
every week or you them every.
Week? No, I record it every single
week. Fresh every week. Every week.
I record. And you're thinking of
your audience and then you pull up.
The phone. Exactly. And
what I usually do, honestly,
literally before I'll do a video.
I'll go on dms or I'll go on messages
and I'll read 50 of 'em and I'll
hear, man, my mom says I'm crazy. My
dad thinks I'm nuts. And I'll be like,
oh my God, these people are
letting the wrong people guide him.
I turn on the camera
and I'll be like, Hey,
bad advice is the most
costly advice in the world,
and I'll talk about advice for 10 minutes.
So it usually comes from their
comments and what they're looking for.
As simple as that sounds,
I don't think there could be anything
better than answering what they need.
Right. It's.
Great. It gets you in the
mindset of what they're thinking.
Do you then use that time since you're
already set up and you're feeling the
vibe to then record more content, more
videos for other purposes or just.
What I used to do before life got so easy
with iPhones and I got a little setup
in my car or wherever I go,
is I used to go in the studio and I'd
film once a week and I'd film a whole
bunch of content. Now, a lot
of times, if I'm feeling it,
I'll literally pull over on the side of
the road and film it or I'll film it at
an event like this. It's more
spontaneous now than ever,
and I think it's more authentic now than
ever because it's not sit down in the
studio, I'm ready to go. It's like, no,
I'm having an emotion right now
and I want to share that emotion.
And I'll be honest with you,
as much as I think I'm transparent
in my marketing and sales,
I've dedicated 2019 to go to another
level of authenticity. I want people,
especially, that's why I want to work
with you, you're so great at that,
is I want people to know
the real me even more.
And I think we're at a place
that that's what people want.
So what's missing from what you're
doing that will transmit that better.
When a camera goes on, I
always feel obligated to teach.
I always feel obligated to
deliver a massive message.
And I think that's why our following,
I think we got 300,000 new Instagram
followers organically just this year
because we said we were there,
and I do a video every day,
so I want to put the
effort in YouTube as well.
But I'm always in that mode of
trying to teach and deliver.
And the biggest comment we get our
dean, we just want to see your life.
We just want to know more about you.
When the camera's off and
you're not sharing something,
what does this look like?
What kind of father are you?
What does it look like at baseball
practice? So I've been saying it forever,
but this is the year I'm committing to
exposing that to the level they want to
see. I don't want to do it in
egoic way, look at my life,
but it seems to be our number one thing.
So what would a message, I mean,
we're here, we're doing an interview,
we've got a room of people. What
would a version of that look like?
Pretend there's no cameras on and
we're just having a conversation.
You don't have to teach.
What would you want to.
Share?
Things like parenting moments when you
make a decision as a parent and you go in
the other room and go, man, I
blew that. And it feels horrible.
And it's horrific. It's not that so
many people watching aren't parents,
but there's a million of those moments
that suck. And I want people to see that.
I go outside and take a walk and I'm mad
at myself and I contemplate why I did
it. And I call a friend who I think is a
great parent. I'll call my buddy Ethan,
who happens to be here right now.
Or I'll call somebody I admire in that
space and say, I handled this wrong.
What do you think? And that suffering,
that pain and then fix it and
then going in and fixing it.
Or that could be with a business partner,
you got a business partner and you ask
for too much or you didn't do enough in
the partnership.
Or I think the biggest benefit of
seeing aspirational videos
online is to see that you can,
but I think there's a bigger byproduct
of that that most people don't recognize
is I think when some people see the
wealth and the private jets and the
Lamborghinis and the happy lives and
the six pack and the pretty girl or the
handsome guy, there's a
percentage of the population,
I bet you half that don't get
encouraged. They get discouraged.
They look and go, I could never look
that good. I could never have that money.
I could never live that life.
They don't have the problems I do.
They don't have the fights I do. They
don't make bad parenting decisions.
They don't hurt their partners like I did.
And I think the world needs to know
that that happens to all of us at every
single level. If we're millionaires,
billionaires, if we're the Pope,
we do that stuff and I think people need
it just so they go, holy, wait, wait,
I can get there. And Dean
screws up all the time.
I want people to see so many people are
like, Dean, you got it all together.
And I'm always like, no, I don't.
I want people to see more of
what I don't have together.
So today, how have you screwed up.
Today? Today, how I screwed up? Let's.
Show it. Let's show the side. Yeah.
Yesterday I have a business
partner I'm doing business with,
and I was in a hurry and I left a message
little, this is tiny, this is nothing.
There's much bigger things than
this. But I'll tell you yesterday,
right before I got here,
I was in a hurry and I left a
message and I hit send and I said,
wow.
I made that whole entire
message about me and the way I
approached it in my head, I
felt like I was being selfish,
and I try to analyze those thoughts and
things I do, and I have to be honest,
I didn't get a reply back until after
lunch and it bugged me for the first four
hours I was sitting here yesterday.
I'm like, man, that was all about me.
This is a good dude. And I
contemplated and I thought,
but what I did is I went through a
process of how I would never do it again,
how I learned from it, and
then I sent the text. I said,
right before I even got a reply,
I sent the text. I said, man,
I hope my enthusiasm
didn't come off wrong.
I made that entire conversation about
me. I like building reciprocity,
and I just said a little something and
I got back this four minute amazing
message. I went in a better
mood at one like, dude,
you're the most giving
human being in the world.
But no one would know that I sat in a
group of amazing people for four hours and
every 15 minutes like, damn, why'd
I send that? I send that, right?
That's little, that's tiny.
But it's also the same things that people
contemplate when they go in for a job
that they don't really like and they said
the wrong thing to the boss or they're
uncomfortable around a coworker.
All these things match.
And I want people to see that we can
be imperfect in so many ways and still
reach heights of success
we'd never imagined. I mean,
I suck at a lot of things,
but I'm really good at a few and I
think we can help people with that.
So in talking to you before all this,
you've now seems like made a decision
to blow up even more and now build the
brand and move from just direct
marketing to actually brand building.
What has to change in the dean
grad C o c mindset or skillset
to make that happen?
Really good question is I'm a
really private person and Jeremy who
works with, we've been trying for
three years to get more of that video,
get somebody to spend more
time with me and do that.
It's that I want to be
transparent and open and I don't
mind sharing it.
I have to surround myself and
schedule more video time where people
catch that side of me. The more real side
of me, I shouldn't say the more real.
I speak from the heart. I'm
always saying the same. But again,
I'm always in teach mode. I think it's
time for people to see the other side,
the sides that you struggle on to get
there. So I think it's just committing.
I think it's just committing to it.
How much of it is not wanting to
show your wife or your kids or
private life, other people versus
just showing you what you're doing.
So you want the most transparent
thing I've ever shared on video.
I can tell you're just
going that direction. So
I didn't show a lot of that for years
because I knew I was going through a
divorce for the last five, seven
years. My ex is a great lady.
We're dear friends. She's a dear
friend of mine. Not just like, oh,
kind of friend. We talk every
day. We co-parent amazing.
But we both knew our
relationship was ending,
but we're both scared to death about
our kids. Both of us come from divorce.
So both of us didn't want
to do that to our kids.
And I didn't share my
personal life because of that.
I knew it was going to end and
I didn't want to be a hypocrite.
And I never talked about
relationships on camera.
I never gave advice about love because I
felt like I was a failure really bad in
that part. And it's been a couple
of years. My divorce is final.
I'm in the best relationship of my
life. My ex is in a great relationship.
Our kids are thriving. We get along.
My ex and my girlfriend soon to be,
I'm betting wife within this year,
went to dinner twice last week, and
they're friends and they talk every day.
I'm in a place right now where I'm
ready to show the world my private life,
my girlfriend, my kids, my house.
But I kept that so quiet for so long.
It was kind of an inner thing that
bugged me. I knew that part wasn't right.
People talk a lot about authenticity,
and you've brought it up a lot,
and I think the actual answer is share
the thing that you're most afraid of
sharing, because people don't want to
learn from the perfect person. Absolutely.
Knowing that you're
struggling with this thing.
So what's the next thing you're
struggling with that if it happens,
maybe not relationship, it's great,
but something else that's coming up that
maybe you're struggling with right now
to say, Hey, Dean,
right now isn't perfect.
You're struggling with these things
and showing us the journey behind the
curtains that you don't
have the answers yet.
Now your life is great
at the homicide. But.
Yeah, so I would say at any other
time I'd have things are really
more than ever in my life,
every area of my life.
This is the first time we're in a
high level mastermind that Joe and I
originally created two and
a half, three years ago.
And we do this exercise with a little
wagon wheel of where are you with your
health, your energy, your income,
your family, your friends, your love.
And that thing always looked like
a jagged wheel. Lots of money,
lots of this fun's great. Oh, this is
not good. This is the first time ever.
It's a really round wheel in my
life. My businesses are going great.
Like I said,
my partners have several different
partners in different areas.
I love all of 'em. They're dear friends.
They have the same mission to
make an impact on the world.
So the only thing I'm struggling right
now is opportunity overload. I have a
core business that is made
up of multiple businesses.
I have 13 different companies
and they're rock solid.
But I know this is like every
entrepreneurial's journey.
Most of us have a level and
then we go through chaos,
and then there's another level
and chaos and another level.
This is kind of the chaos, but happy
chaos as I go to the next level.
So what I'm struggling
with the most is just time.
I still pick up my kids from school
three or four days a week and nothing.
I left here,
I was here yesterday at this event I had
left because it was my turn to pick up
the kids. Nothing. I don't compromise
that for anything or anybody.
There's nobody that could
take me away from that.
That's what success means to me. I still
coach little league. I coach softball.
I coach flag football. So I want to be
wealthy there in time and connection with
my kids.
That's my number one determining factor
of wealth in my life is I connected to
my kids, my connected to my girlfriend.
Nothing else is really
more important than that.
Secondly is my partners and
my connection with them.
And third is the impact of the world.
And right now they're all kind of
hitting on all cylinders except for the
overwhelm of so many great opportunities
coming. So right now it's the scramble,
depending on when you see this video,
but it'll be out or maybe not yet,
but Tony and s and I are launching a
course and getting all the pieces together
for,
it's something that we think is going to
impact the world for the next 40 years.
So it's not like this little, oh, we're
throwing something out there. It's like,
this is Tony and i's legacy
in this niche of the world.
So it's a stressor because I
want to make sure it's right.
I want to over deliver to the world.
What would your typical message be to
somebody if they went through that wagon
wheel exercise and they were
hitting it on all cylinders,
what would you tell that.
Person if they were hitting
it on all cylinders?
I'd probably say the full of shit.
And any other time in my life I would
say that, but shit, no, I feel blessed,
but I would or.
Another version of it. Are
you inside your comfort zone?
No. Hell no.
I push myself outside the comfort
zone all the time in every area.
But you have to understand,
I just got out of a wake of one of the
worst periods of my life personally going
through that divorce. Nothing has
affected me like that. Transparency.
When people said they had
anxiety or an anxiety attack,
I used to think that meant I
had anxiety. I was anxious,
but leaving my kids and
only seeing 'em half a week,
half of the week when I used to make 'em
breakfast every day and Sunday was my
family meeting days, I went into straight
anxiety attacks for about six months.
I couldn't sleep at night. I
was popping Xanax once a week.
I was drinking wine three days a
week and flying all over the world,
meeting with Tony Robbins and Dr. A Amen
and the best specialist on the planet.
I thought I was losing my mind. So
I just came out of that, not just,
but in the last year, but I worked
myself. In fact, I went through it today,
but I worked through a process. I just
used all the personal growth. Literally.
I'm not just saying what it's like.
Joe used a great line of
eat your own dog food.
I literally went through the process
that I teach. I literally went through,
Hey, I'm painting a really bad
picture. I'm stacking all the negative.
Let me stack the positive. Who
do I not want to be to my kids?
Who do I want to be to my kids?
What's my compelling future?
Who can I gain knowledge from? Can I
watch these videos, read this book,
go see some friends? And then
how do I put that in play?
And literally such proof of concept.
It's what's taken my passion to another
level of wanting help people.
It's why I want to work with you.
It's why I want to get more exposure
is because going through that process,
I realize how damn lucky I am
because I have amazing friends,
because I've been in
personal growth for 20 years.
I have all these at my fingertips.
Money's not a problem. I have all this.
And I still went through
six months of hell.
And when I got through
the other side, one day,
the hell ended literally one day.
It was like life went to another level
immediately like a thousand pounds got
let out, childhood worries, and things
that affected my childhood went away.
I attracted the best love in my life.
My business has literally almost
tripled since my divorce was final,
literally because I'm free.
I don't wake up every morning. I woke up
for five years every morning of my life
and I'd say, am I going to
leave this week? Literally,
and this is someone who works on
his personal growth every day,
but I'd see my kids and go, I can't leave.
So when I say I'm
hitting on all cylinders,
I just went through that Six
months from now, a year from now,
it might be the next struggle, but
right now I feel like in heaven.
So the only reason I'm sharing that is
because I have all these assets at my
fingertips. And I thought I was
losing it. I'm not kidding. I said,
I made it till this age and I cracked. I
crushed it till now, and now I cracked.
And then I'm like, what if
I feel this way forever?
So when I got around the other side of
that, and I'm on a whole nother level,
I said,
what about most people that don't have
access to be friends with Tony Robbins
and Dr.
A Amen,
and Joe Polish and Ethan Willis and
Brendan Burchard and all these guys that
came around and just helped
with the process. I hired
two different consultants.
I've been working in
personal growth for 20 years.
Most people don't have
access to any of that.
So they just live in that misery
thinking that's the rest of their life.
And if you want to talk about something
that gives you passion and drive to push
people and help people, that's
why I'm pushing my book. I mean,
we're at 470,000 copies of my new
book. I need that to get to a million.
I'm writing my next book. I'm
creating the best courses in my life.
It's why I Tony and I partnered together.
It's about impact and
giving people options.
Because most people watching
this right now, even Evan,
they'll watch it and maybe they'll be
inspired. Maybe they'll find one thing,
but when they shut that video
off, a lot of 'em go back and go,
but you don't know what I'm dealing with.
And they go right back to where they
were.
How do we do things that it's so
impactful and so obvious that they
take nuggets every time they watch and
they actually put it in their life,
not just because inspiration is great,
but how long does inspiration last,
right? They watch a video, you feel great.
It's like you go to an event and
for three days you feel amazing.
Fourth day fades. Two weeks later,
you're right back where you were.
So what I love about what
you do, and I mean this,
our team watches your videos all the time,
is it's consistent and ongoing and never
stop. It's what people need every day.
It's like, I dunno about you.
I would bet to say it's like
most people think they can.
It's like going to the gym for the
weekend and workout like crazy and they're
going to be in shape forever.
Personal development,
personal growth is the same thing. I need
it. I about you. I need it every day.
Every day. I can't go a day
without listening to a book,
watching audio or talk to somebody
or even sharing it to somebody else.
As I'm sharing it, I'm learning. I need
it every day. So what you do is amazing.
And that's, I'm in the same space. I
just want to give people the tools.
There's a great interview clip of Elon
Musk going on C N B C, and he says,
the world's going to end because the
AI and robots are going to kill us.
And then some reporters ask him, well,
how is it going to happen? And he says,
I don't know. And they ask a bunch
of follow-up questions and he says,
I don't know. I watched that
clip. And I think to myself,
I don't know that I would
have the courage to say,
I don't know on national TV to
a bold claim that I just made.
I look at that and I think the next
time I get asked a question that I don't
know the answer to, I hope I have the
courage say, I know to say I don't know.
No matter who's watching.
So why I'm asking that is,
you are going down this
path of authenticity,
which is the next evolution of your brand.
The next time something like that happens
where you feel like your life might be
falling or cracking and you're the guy
who's supposed to have it all figured
out, you think you have
the courage to say.
Hands down, I can't help
people if I don't share.
And that's what I learned through
it. I kept it quiet. I did.
I thought people needed me stronger. And
when you say everything leads you to,
the reason you do what
you do is, I don't know,
a hundred percent of your journey,
but all those things led
you to have this passion.
My passion of being authentic is not
because I want to sell more books.
I can help more people
because I suffered alone.
A handful of my friends knew the rest
of the world. I still got on video like,
Hey everybody, what's up?
What's up Dean Graziosi?
And then I go home and pound a glass of
wine and hope to fall asleep because I
didn't sleep for two nights before
that. I'll never do that again.
I'll never not let the world see that.
Cool, man. Well, thank you
for the time today. Awesome.
Thank you for sharing your story.
You're awesome. Keep up the good work.
Man. I super pump to see
where you take everything.
In. Yeah. You got it, bro. First off,
thanks to Believe Nation for
doing such an amazing job.
If you want to watch more of my videos,
look at the link in the description
and go to my YouTube channel.
If you want more Dean Graziosi, check
at the Top 10 Rules video made on him.
The link is right there next
to me. I think you'll enjoy it.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you there.
Most of the time.
Our next level of life lives on the
other side of our biggest obstacle.
I wanted to be successful because I hated
not being in control of my life as a
kid.